fini ce journal avec un personnage culte
tintin désormais le petit reporter va
s'exprimer en hindi et dans une dizaine
de dialectes utilisé en inde
jusqu'à présent il n'y parlait que
l'anglais jean françois furet jack en
kiosque gaz à l'état de carcasse à
carhaix il parlait déjà 58 langues
depuis quelques semaines tintin le
reporter belge à la houppette blonde
manie aussi les dialectes régionaux
indien le telugu le tamoul le malayalam
est aussi l'un de ses patines en amont
là bas les enfants l'appellent tin tin
milou est devenu snowy et s'il adore
c'est pour les mêmes raisons que nous il
est gentil drôle et toujours courageux
il est intelligent et surtout il se fait
jamais mal l'inde connaît c'est tintin
en anglais uniquement en traduisant ses
aventures ses éditeurs sont en passe de
conquérir un nouveau marché
ils ont vendu 40 mille dvd en un mois ce
programme est populaire pourquoi les
gens qui ne parlent pas anglais
n'aurait-il pas le droit de le regarder
à bientôt 77 ans tintin devient une
vedette à l'autre bout du monde tonnerre
de brest ou plutôt bas d'acter hubei
ngan